today i want to talk about neutrinos
they're fundamental particles here they
are on the standard model of particle
physics and they're created in the
fusion reactions in the sun which gives
out a colossal 10 to the 38 neutrinos
every second
then a massive 10 to the 29 pass right
through the earth every second as if
it's not there and 300 trillion pass
right through your body every second
which is why they are often referred to
in mainstream media as ghost particles
because so many pass through our bodies
without us noticing we definitely
shouldn't be able to see them with our
eyes but i figured out that there's a
very slight chance that one of them
could hit an atom in your eyeball and
cause a visible flash of light
the chance of this happening to you is
very small but because there's so many
human eyeballs on the planet roughly 10
people per hour on earth will have a
neutrino collide with one of their eyes
now nothing bad would happen you'd just
see a very faint flash of blue light but
i've never heard anyone talk about this
before even though according to my
calculations it's true
neutrinos are the weirdest particle in
the standard model and the ones we
understand the least there are four main
reasons why they're weird
first of all they're the only particles
that only interact with other particles
via the weak force
there are four forces in nature gravity
electromagnetism and the nucleus strong
and weak forces
and the weak force is cold weak because
it's very short-ranged which means that
it's only felt by particles that are
really really close together like 10 to
the minus 18 meters apart that's a
thousand times smaller than the nucleus
of an atom which is already incredibly
small
this is why neutrinos go through your
body as if it's not there because to
them we just look like empty space
technically neutrinos also feel gravity
but they've got such tiny masses and
gravity is so weak we can basically
ignore it
in fact that's the second weird thing
about neutrinos we've got no idea where
they get their mass from
all the other particles with mass get
their mass from the higgs field but
neutrinos get theirs from somewhere else
and we've got no idea where they get it
from
also when neutrinos are flying through
space they morph from one kind to
another this is the only particle in the
standard model that spontaneously
changes into another particle
and finally we've only ever seen
left-handed neutrinos and right-handed
anti-neutrinos
all other particles come in both
left-handed or right-handed kinds of
particle and anti-particle but not
neutrinos
for more information about all this
check out my video and post on the
standard model of particle physics
in fact in case you are on the lookout
for presence around now i've got a load
of educational posters available in my
store dosmaps.com and i also have a
range of kids books for the youngsters
covering space physics the human body
and the oceans
dosmaps.com link in the description
below
anyway like i said neutrinos are weird
and we don't understand them well
because they rarely interact with
anything
despite them being the most abundant
particle in the universe we think
there's even more neutrinos than there
are photons of light and even though
neutrinos have incredibly small masses
less than 10 to the minus 37 kilograms
the combined mass of all the neutrinos
is about the same as all the stars in
the universe
so to try and understand neutrinos we've
built a load of giant detectors
underground to try and detect the very
rare occasions where they do get close
enough to collide with mata
this is what a neutrino detector looks
like this one's called super cameo kande
and it's deep underground to stop any
other particles getting through to it
it's a giant vat 50 000 meters cubed of
volume filled with ultra pure water
surrounded by photo multipliers which
are basically very sensitive cameras
other neutrino detectors follow similar
designs but are filled with different
kinds of liquid which absorb different
energies of neutrinos
when a neutrino collides with one of the
electrons in the liquid the electron
absorbs their energy and whizzes off
through the liquid giving out a special
kind of light called cherenkov radiation
cherenkov radiation is kind of like a
sonic boom but for light because the
electrons travel faster than light does
in the liquid
which sounds weird because it sounds
like i'm saying electrons travel faster
than light well yes they do but only
because light slows down in a liquid
the electrons don't go faster than light
in a vacuum that's the thing that's
impossible but you can go faster than
light if you slow down light enough like
in a liquid and in that case you'll emit
this cherenkov radiation
so with these massive vats of liquid
people are seeing the sporadic neutrino
impacts collecting data and trying to
figure out how neutrinos really work
which is all good science and all that
but i was thinking these detectors look
kind of like big eyes
if you think about it our eyes are vats
of liquid and your retinas are sensitive
to light like the photomultipliers
so if a neutrino hit an electron in your
eye would it also create cherenkov
radiation and could you see it
of course our eyes are way smaller than
these giant detectors but we have a lot
of eyes
so i tried to figure it all out with
maths and i also ran it past a professor
of these things and yeah there's a very
small chance a neutrino will collide
with your eye gloop and create a flash
of light
but this will only happen to you on
average once every 89 000 years
so you'll probably never see one but
there are a lot of human eyes on earth
in fact if you collected all the human
eyeballs on earth right now you could
fill up super cameo candy twice over
and that's why i love physics
anyway averaging all this out over the
7.7 billion people on earth we can
expect around 10 people per hour will
get a neutrino colliding with one of
their eyeballs
but i hear you shout how visible would
this be would we even be able to see it
well our eyes are pretty sensitive to
light if you're in a dark room you can
register flashes of as little as 10
photons and cherenkov radiation from the
neutrino impact creates around 200
visible photons per centimeter through
the eye
200 photons is way bigger than 10
so a neutrino impact would be visible
but only if you're in the dark because
it would get swamped by daylight
also there are some subtleties with what
angle the neutrino hits your eye and
whether the cone of the cherenkov light
overlaps with your retina
i'm not an eyeball expert so i don't
really know how that would affect the
statistics but even if it's like 10
times lower that's still one person an
hour on earth
we know that astronauts have seen light
flashes inside their eyes when they
travel outside the earth's magnetosphere
these are thought to be caused by cosmic
rays but we don't really get this on
earth because we're mostly protected by
the magnetosphere and the atmosphere but
still some get through so we might get
flashes of light in our eyes caused by
cosmic rays or even background radiation
from the earth
but i think it's very cool that if you
see a random flash of blue light in your
eye you might be looking at the remnants
of the most mysterious particle in the
universe although i should mention that
statistically it's much more likely to
be a detached retina so
uh if it does keep happening best to go
see an ophthalmologist
anyway i'm genuinely interested to see
if any of you have seen a faint blue
flash in one of your eyes if we get 90
000 people to watch this video there's a
good chance that one of you has seen
this in the last year so i'm interested
to find out let me know in the comments
below if that's happened to you and if
you want to learn the skills to do this
kind of physics based problem solving
yourself a fantastic place to start is
brilliant who are sponsoring this part
of the video
they're a website and app where you
learn subjects in science and
mathematics by actively solving problems
the thing i love about having learned
physics is the tool kit it gives you to
creatively figure out how to answer any
strange question you might come up with
like is it possible to see a neutrino
and to get good at this you need lots of
practice solving puzzles and brilliant
is a fantastic place to do this and
learn the fundamental concepts in
physics at the same time they have a
wide selection of courses in physics
going from quantum mechanics to
relativity and a whole load of other
courses in mathematics and computer
science with lots of interactive
elements to play with if you're
interested just go to brilliant.org dos
and if you're one of the first 200
people to sign up via that link you'll
get a 20 discount off your premium
subscription which unlocks all of their
content
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you in the next video
you